[Music]
it is national consumer protection week
here's a look at several common schemes
what to do if you suspect a scam or have
become the victim of a scammer
scammers are always coming up with new
ways to try to get our money bernard
bermudez managed to avoid becoming the
victim of one recently thanks to a
conscientious uber driver i hopped into
the uber car
and the um the driver told me to put a
pin number
and he asked me for a pin i'm gonna go
what pin number and so i had to put in a
pin number and he had to match it up on
his phone i asked him why did they do
that and he said to me that there's a
lot of fraud going on with the uber
space and
maybe 20 seconds after that happened
somebody pinged him pretending he was me
bermudez is also a vice president with
enterprise bank and trust here in las
vegas he says common scams they're
seeing include phony usps text messages
citing a reason for a missed delivery
directing the person to a website to pay
for a re-delivery and the card
information is then stolen bermuda says
the scam is often used during tax refund
season if you are expecting a delivery
call or stop by your local post office
instead and don't trust a text
another common scam travel sites with
the property listed for rent where a
person asked to be paid outside of the
system to avoid fees never pay for
services outside the system because you
will have a more difficult time
recovering your money
if and when something goes wrong and
also if you get an email or a text
message from your bank or your credit
card company or anyone asking you to do
something pick up the phone and call the
bank's telephone number do not call back
to the number that sent you the text
if you suspect a scam call the ftc the
federal trade commission is the main
agency that collects scam reports and if
you think you have become a victim of
fraud report potentially compromised
bank account credit or debit card
information to your financial
institutions immediately